There's no denying that Marvel Comics have
made their superheroes just as famous on the
big screen as the comic book page - but it
didn't come without some problems.
While the Avengers may be dominating the box
office, the X-Men churning out sequels and
spinoffs by the year, and even Deadpool becoming
a blockbuster hit, the road here isn't all
smooth sailing.
And the worst moments can be hard to forget.
Here are 10 Marvel Movie Moments That Outraged
Fans.
Emo Spider-Man
The moment Tobey Maguire was cast as Peter
Parker was enough of a shock.
But the actor pulled off the challenge in
two Spider-Man films, getting better from
one to the next.
Then Spider-Man 3 happened, and Peter had
a bit of a personality crisis.
Director Sam Raimi was probably going for
some offbeat laughs, but the insane antics
of "emo Spider-Man" turned of most fans, and
helped kill the franchise fast.
Jean Grey Kills Cyclops
Fans may have forgotten about Jean Grey going
crazy and murdering Professor X in X-Men 3,
since Bryan Singer apparently did, too, returning
him to life in Days of Future Past.
But as bad as it was to see him killed, Cyclops
faced and even worse fate.
The first two movies had failed to deliver
the eye-blasting leader fans knew and loved,
but why director Brett Ratner thought it was
smart to have Jean kill him off, in the first
minutes of the movie - OFF SCREEN - is a question
that can never be answered.
Fantastic Four's Galactus
The first Fantastic Four may not have been
perfect, but it stopped short of making unforgivable
mistakes - something that can't be said for
the sequel.
We'll never know why anyone thought it wise
to put Jessica Alba in the worst blue contacts
and bleach-blonde wig we've ever seen, but
when the fan-favorite Marvel villain Galactus
became a cloud in space, the fans turned their
backs completely.
Fantastic Four's Final Fight
Why kill a movie franchise just once, when
you can pull it off twice?
Fans had nothing but hope for Josh Trank to
reinvent Marvel's Fantastic Family, but by
the time it released, reports of studio interference
and massive reshoots made it clear nobody
was happy with the movie going to theaters.
There was plenty wrong with the reboot, but
the soulless, boring, and downright awful
final battle put the previous version of the
team to shame.
Daredevil's Seesaw Battle
Star Ben Affleck may not have been the reason
that the Daredevil movie fell flat, but it's
hard to get fans to agree on what WAS... until
you mention the playground fight scene with
Elektra.
In hindsight, a movie in which a woman fighting
a blind man on a see-saw seemed totally plausible
probably isn't going to be a hit with everyone.
The movie may have dumber moments, but it
was this scene that started the eyes rolling
until the final credits.
The Mandarin
When it was announced that Tony Stark would
finally battle the evil Mandarin in Iron Man
3, Marvel fans were thrilled - or at least
curious to see how the studio would handle
the villain, originally a pretty obvious racial
stereotype.
The outrage started when Sir Ben Kingsley
was cast in the role, but the other shoe fell
when even his version was revealed to be the
performance of a bumbling actor - one massive
joke from director Shane Black that tons of
Marvel fans found anything but funny.
Storm vs. Toad
Look on any list of the worst comic book movie
moments, or dumbest lines of dialogue, and
you're guaranteed to find Storm's lame zinger
("what happens to a toad when it's struck
by lightning).
Avengers director Joss Whedon has since claimed
credit for the line, meant as an actual joke,
and never intended to be read as a tough-talking
one-liner.
It might be the worst moment in Bryan Singer's
run on the mutant team, and it's one that
fans or critics will never forget.
Wolverine's Magic Bullet
What's the one thing that could make a clunky,
confused, cheesy Wolverine movie worse than
an absolute butchering of Deadpool?
How about delivering an Adamantium bullet
to the hero's brain, making sure he'd never
remember his own origin story.
Since it made the previous two hours completely
meaningless to the larger series, and actually
caused even MORE continuity problems, fans
were justified in hating what the studio had
done to one of its most beloved stars and
characters.
The Death of Coulson
After shining in a small Iron Man role, Agent
Phil Coulson started moving up in the MCU,
becoming a full blown main cast member in
Iron Man 3 and The Avengers.
And just when fans couldn't love Coulson or
actor Clark Gregg any more, he got his most
badass moment standing up to Loki himself...
before getting a spear through his chest,
and dying minutes later.
It made the Avengers a team, but outraged
and crushed fans everywhere... almost as much
as when Marvel returned Coulson from the dead
for Agents of SHIELD.
So... take your pick.
Deadpool's Debut
For years, Ryan Reynolds had fans convinced
that he would make the perfect Deadpool, and
he finally got his chance... as a back-up
character and villain in X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
His debut as the un-powered Wade Wilson proved
the studio had gotten the casting right, but
by the time he was revealed, mutated, scarred,
and inexplicably silenced, it was as disappointing
as the rest of the movie.
Thankfully, it earned him a second shot.
Those are just some of the Marvel Movie Moments
that had fans furious, turned off, or fed
up.
But which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!